okay wait before you dislike the video
Let Me Explain I love Gojo he's my
favorite character in Jutsu Kaizen along
with my boy Toto and I think he's one of
the best overpowered anime characters of
this era but Gojo's Limitless power and
Limitless Riz are the very reasons why
the author of jjk has to keep taking him
out of the story time after time and
it's also the reason why people are now
freaking out and threatening to drop
Jutsu kaisen because of what happened to
Gojo in this video I will cover three
key points that explain why Gojo is both
the best character in jjk and the
absolute worst character for the overall
story just hear me out Point number
three will definitely Intrigue you so
let's get into it jumping right into
Point number one Gojo is overpowered
yeah like obviously Gojo is an absolute
menace to the entire sorcerer world just
by being born he completely messed up
the balance of the universe curses
literally had to become stronger after
he was born to make up for the fact that
the sorcerers were about to become so
stacked he was the first person in 400
years to be born with both the six size
and Limitless he's also one of the
strongest Sorcerers in the history of
the world and he single-handedly carried
the Gojo Clan to the very height of
power and influence the other major
sorcerer families were so scared of him
that they tried to assassinate him when
he was a little kid like they were
literally so scared of this child that
they wanted to kill him but the
Assassins they hired couldn't even come
close to hurting goat Joe he quickly
grew into the Undisputed strongest
Sorcerer of the modern era and he would
say that he was also the strongest
Sorcerer of all time he is so strong
that if technology ran on cursed energy
rather than like gas or electricity Gojo
would apparently be able to power the
entire United States on his own in the
past ghetto said that Gojo has the power
to destroy all of humanity so yeah this
guy is incredibly powerful and he knows
it Gojo is supremely confident and he
said himself that throughout Heaven and
Earth he alone is the honored one I mean
at one point he was even bragging that
he could take the king of Cur versus
sukuna in his prime to the absolute
Delight of the fans Gojo would
eventually get the chance to face sukuna
in battle but although that fight was
epic it also led to the wildest and most
controversial moments in the entire
series it's a moment that we as fans are
still trying to process and if it's not
handled extremely carefully going
forward it could bring down the entire
story of jujuu kaisen if you're
wondering what I mean by that stick
around you're about to find out but okay
you guys get it Gojo is overpowered so
what there are lots of overpowered
characters in anime and manga and that
doesn't have to screw up the whole
series this is where I raise you point
number two Gojo's RZ it's not just that
Gojo is a supremely overpowered
character who just kind of stays in the
background or is someone we know about
but only really get to meet towards the
end of the story he shows up right at
the beginning to Mentor Yugi and the
other students and he is such a
charismatic badass that he absolutely
steals the show don't get me wrong there
are a lot of great characters in and jjk
but Gojo is definitely my personal
favorite and whenever he is on screen he
upstages everyone initially the only one
who came close to stealing Gojo's
Thunder was toi but in the end it was
curtains for toi as well I mean even gig
the author knows how much of a fan
favorite Gojo is because the prequel
deals heavily with Gojo and his
friendship with ghetto and there's also
an entire Arc in the manga that focuses
on Gojo's backstory but then you're
probably thinking okay Gojo is
overpowered and he is a fan favorite
Jutsu rizzler so what the issue is that
Gojo is not the main character he is a
mentor side character who is there to
guide Yugi noar and megumi through their
Journey but a personality like Gojo's is
too big to be contained by the label of
a side character and this really begins
to show during the Shibuya incident oh
by the way can you do me a big favor and
drop a like right now to make up for all
the dislikes I'm going to get for saying
the word rizzler thank you so much as I
said earlier when Gojo was born curses
literally had had to get stronger in
order to make up for how stacked the
sorcerer side became thanks to his birth
this is actually symbolic of what the
author G had to deal with when the plot
really got going and especially after we
hit the big boy arcs like Shibuya
because Gojo is so strong the villains
have to be extremely strong as well
otherwise Gojo will easily crush them
and the story would be boring there
would be no tension since Gojo would
solo everyone easily so gay had to give
us extremely powerful curses and
overpowered ancient enemies like Kaku
and sukuna just so they could be a
challenge for Gojo but here's the
problem our main character Yuji along
with other characters like noada and
megumi are still just firste students so
it doesn't make sense for them to
already be able to take on these
insanely powerful villains now of course
if the other characters aren't strong
enough on their own to take out the
villains they can always work together
and use teamwork to come out on top but
as long as Gojo is around teamwork seems
kind of pointless because Gojo can just
come and take care of it much quicker
and easier why risk your life and worry
about teamwork when you have the
strongest Sorcerer of the modern era on
speed dial all of this comes together
into Point number three as long as Gojo
is around the other characters can't
grow with Gojo gig created a Riz monster
an overpowered and Incredibly popular
character whom everyone loves but a
character whose very existence makes it
almost impossible for the other
characters like Yuji to actually grow
basically the only way to stop Gojo from
always stealing the show and the only
way to allow less powerful characters
like Yuji to step up and become great
Sorcerers in their own room right is to
remove Gojo from the story this is
exactly what G does in Shibuya Gojo is
taken out of the picture by being sealed
away and then the other characters are
forced to step up and take
responsibility for saving the world and
for rescuing Gojo but even though this
Gojo Hiatus allowed other characters to
grow and shine you better believe that a
ton of people in the jjk fan Community
were complaining and saying where's Gojo
we need Gojo I'm not reading until they
bring back Gojo and so on eventually g g
gave in and Gojo was released but then
as soon as he came out of the seal we
went right back to the same setup Gojo
came out fast and furious rushed out to
face off against kakuen sukuna and he
stole the show Once Again everything
after that was first a countdown to the
big Gojo versus sua fight and then when
the fight started the entire Focus was
on the fight itself Yuji and the other
sorcerers were literally watching from
the sidelines as the big battle went
down and for most of it they were just
like commentators giving us a play-
byplay of what was happening in the
fight at this point gay basically had
three options option one Gojo wins if
this happens then the story is basically
over sukuna is by far the strongest
villain and if he loses then Gojo just
sweeps Kaku and all the rest and it's
game over you either have to bring in a
new alien villain like kaguya out of
nowhere to keep things challenging for
Gojo or the good guys win and it ends
there option two the fight ends in some
kind of draw either both Gojo and sukuna
die or the fight just ends with with
both of them living to fight another day
but then you're just delaying the
inevitable round two between them it's
kind of like mha where we had deu versus
shigaraki in jaku and then a few arcs
pass and then again we have Deku versus
shigaraki in the final Arc there was
always going to be a rematch option
three is what actually happened although
the way it happened made a lot of people
very angry chapter 235 ended with Gojo
wrecking sukam and in the final panel
kusakabe even declared that Gojo won
then in in the very next chapter things
switched up completely as we learned
that Gojo had apparently been killed off
screen so not only did Gojo not win all
of a sudden he is now dead and sukuna is
the winner even if you think that sukuna
killing Gojo makes sense and that it's a
good twist for the story the way it was
done caused major Whiplash for a lot of
people myself included and a ton of the
most dedicated Gojo stands were really
really mad people were threatening to
drop the jjk manga if Gojo wasn't
brought back somehow they were saying
that without Gojo the other sorcerers
have no way of defeating sukuna and if
they do win in the end it's going to be
an aspull they were saying that all the
other fights were going to be boring and
anticlimactic after the big Gojo sukuna
fight and so on I mean you guys are
anime fans you know what happens on
social media every time there's even a
little bit of controversy in an anime or
Manga I don't have to explain it to you
again we know why gig felt like Gojo had
to be removed from the story just like
he was in Shibuya we can't have all the
other characters including the main
characters like Yuji just standing on
the sidelines and giving us a play-
byplay of the fight they need to do
something more they need to play a role
in actually defeating sukuna but when
you're trying to remove a character who
is larger than life and who is as
popular as Gojo it's always going to be
difficult and there's always going to be
some fan backlash that is especially
true if you're planning to remove the
characters suddenly and abruptly and off
screen that is where we are at this
moment Jutsu kaai in his gojol less for
a second time and the focus is now on
all the other characters scrambling to
somehow defeat full power SU sukuna but
realistically can they really do it
without it looking like an asspull where
will the story Go From Here drop me a
line in the comments if you have some
theories about how sukuna could be
defeated without Gojo nevertheless there
is another option that a lot of Gojo
copers have been hoping for when Gojo
was seemingly killed his head was not
damaged meaning that there is still some
possibility of him surviving or coming
back from the dead using a secret
technique or power if that happens and
Gojo helps to defeat sukuna together
with the other sorcerers then sukur's
defeat won't feel like an aspull but
then people will of course say that Gojo
has plot armor and that his apparent
death was a cheap fake out so in the end
it's kind of like gig can't win he can't
just have Gojo single-handedly solving
all the problems in the story but Gojo
is such an epic and popular character
that removing him causes fans to revolt
if Gojo somehow manages to come back
then those fans will be happier but then
other fans will be upset about the fake
out so that is how Gojo accidentally
ruined gig's plans for jjk you can't
just have him steal the show and defeat
every villain but he's too popular to
remove from the story without causing
massive backlash I still think that gig
can pull off an excellent ending to the
story but we got to be real it's not
going to be easy if gag can really pull
it off he deserves Limitless respect now
if you're a Gojo coper like me and
you're wondering how he could still
possibly turn from the dead check out my
video on how Gojo could become a
vengeful Spirit like his ancestor
mugara and evolve Beyond Humanity like
Master Tangen link on screen and in the
description drop a like And subscribe if
you want to keep coping together and
I'll see you in the next
video